well you may have seen this it's all
over the news
after initially denying the accusation
amazon has now admitted that sometimes
the company's drivers are
forced to pee in bottles rather than
take a break from working
amazon is now apologizing for their
reaction
to give us a little more insight i'm now
joined by a human
resources manager at amazon michael
barnes michael welcome hi conan thanks
for having me
all right i'm just going to jump right
in amazon is now admitting
that delivery drivers do in fact
sometimes have to pee
in bottles instead of taking a break
well well conan first of all i've been
told amazon would rather use the word
acknowledge than admit and we'd also
like to clarify they don't have to pee
in bottles they
they get to pee in bottles wait wait
they get to pee in bottles are you
saying it's a special privilege
that's right conan you see amazon is a
wonderful place to work that prides
itself
on being very open and lenient with
their employees
okay michael are you okay of course i
have code and i'm i'm just talking about
amazon's compassionate practices
okay well it doesn't seem very
compassionate of amazon to
let drivers pee in bottles it's not just
the drivers conan it's everyone the
amazon buildings don't have any bathroom
so
every employee gets their own bottle for
number one
okay well all right what what about
number two
a pot with a lid okay wait all right i
mean that's
that's unheard that's medieval that's
disgusting well conan just think
we've saved over 10 million dollars in
plumbing repairs we pee
in bottles so we can pass on the savings
to our customers
you know i'm sorry i honestly can't
believe amazon treats employees like
this
you may have heard a rumor that we're
all locked in a room during our lunch
break and
not allowed to leave but that's just not
true all we have to do is buy a key from
the key
vending machine that we have in there to
unlock the door
okay what can i do to help you tell me
conan please save me okay michael i
think you swapped the sign
and what you meant to say ah okay hold
on
uh amazon is a wonderful place to work
great that fixes everything michael
barnes everybody
thank you
you